hello and welcome to this announcement
video for today's live shows I wasn't on
last week I was not able to speak to a
degree that made a show possible but
that is now a lot better so on again and
I'm on at the usual times and I'm not
starting with my picture here right away
because right before me I'm starting at
7:30 central you paid time right before
me I have a pretty decent opener because
yeah there's a Magnus Ben tablets Magnus
cards and playing Ben tablets on just 24
at 6:00 in the evening Center you picked
on and I'm on 90 minutes later so you
can try play Magnus if you've got a
chess 24 premium or watch his stream
like here right on chess 24 side and
right after that I'm on at 7:30 and AD
that's Jojo the goose shot splits and 19
minutes later the classic Ben tablets in
English so it is for me the usual times
and right before me Magnus is on so
you've got good things to to watch today
and if you've got a chest 24 premium you
can also play against me if you like the
links are in the description thanks
about for watching the announcement